good morning everyone and in case you're
watching this some other time good
afternoon good evening and good night
this is versus the hit show that
everyone at your school was talking
about kids can relate to this show if
not in school anymore congratulations
you made it but chances are during those
formative years you and your pals shared
a great many laughs thanks to the movies
of jim carrey and mike myers although
i'm known for going on a great many
diatribes this is not one of those times
because on the show today it's a comedic
clash of cosmic and canadian consequence
two of the brightest stars of the
hollywood galaxy are going head to head
character to character and catch phrase
the catchphrase is gonna be fun yeah
baby i had to do it you knew it was
coming and it's over now in one corner
it's jim carrey the man of a thousand
faces who's played everything from a pet
detective to a lawyer to a limo driver
who dreams of being a worm salesman i
got worms
i beg your pardon
that's what we're going to call it in
the other it's mike myers who
skyrocketed to fame thanks to snl sketch
characters like wayne campbell and found
success on the big screen as that other
british super spy both gents got their
start on popular sketch shows while
myers was hollering live from new york
it's saturday night carrie was screaming
even louder as the hyper fire marshall
bill on in living color and now decades
after we first met them they've reached
the pinnacle of tinseltown stardom
getting metaphorically tossed into a
proverbial pit from which only one show
emerged victorious because that's what
we do here on verses i'm ready to go in
coach just give me a chance and here is
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three best
characters round four cultural legacy
and then we'll do a wild card round that
might be as simple as which movie i love
more ace ventura pet detective or
wayne's world both competitors have gone
on to make many more films inside and
outside of the comedy genre but that duo
of legendary flicks represents the first
time i saw them on the big screen as a
wii type i left one theater head banging
to queen and the other talking out of my
butt i've been doing both daily ever
since hello
what do you think you're doing only me
and garth get to talk to the camera two
of the all-time titans of talking
pictures are going 10 to 10 but reminder
it's all for fun cool
excellent let's get it on let's get down
to business round one box office
whenever jim carrey competes in a versus
like the time he vanquished adam sandler
way back in season one the topic of box
office comes up and with good reason
carries 1994 is up there with the most
legendary year any entertainer has ever
had and in sports terms that season for
jim carrey ranks with michael phelps's
2012. tiger woods is 2002 and dan
marino's 1984.
hey dan marino is an ace ventura pet
detective which happens to be the movie
that kicked off that legendary 94 run
you don't have to tell me
i was there but before we get to that
mike myers hit it big at the box office
with wayne's world based on the beloved
snl sketch the feature film opened on
valentine's day 1992 and would go on to
amass 183 million dollars worldwide
excuse me
baking powder wayne's world 2 hit the
following year and although it only
grows 47 million dollars there's a
reason for that
everyone was wrong it's like possibly
the greatest comedy sequel ever thank
you
okay i'm not going to go on my full
tirade about this yet but just know it's
coming later in the show cool it was
less than two months after the
disappointing box office for wayne's
world 2 that ace ventura hit theaters
and the comet known as jim carrey struck
hollywood
alrighty then the film shocked the
industry by grossing over a hundred
million dollars out of nowhere
and would be the start of an
unprecedented eight film run
that saw each movie gross at least a
hundred million dollars and six of those
films raking in over 200 million bucks
including the mask in the summer of 94
and dumb and dumber that december enjoy
looking back because you'll never see
another year like that again just sit
back and enjoy the ride oh and jim
carrey's 1995 wasn't all that bad either
the sequel's batman forever and ace
ventura when nature calls teamed up to
gross over 500 million smackers was that
over the top i can never tell meanwhile
mike myers had only made soy married an
axe murderer in addition to his wayne's
world duo as he was still an all-star on
that tiny little saturday night hit tv
show but as jim morrison accurately
predicted in the desert wayne campbell's
alter ego was gearing up to go on a
superb box office run of his own thanks
to another myers-brainchild a british
super spy named austin powers the first
film debuted in 1997 and earned a
respectable 67 million dollars but that
number only hints at the mojo it
generated oh behave
1999's follow-up the spy who shagged me
did 312 million dollars and kicked off a
stretch of five starring roles in a row
that each earned at least 100 million
dollars and at most did almost a billion
bucks thanks to an ogre named shrek why
make trillions when we could make
[Music]
billions
that was shrek too and it built on the
491 million dollar gross of the
inaugural shrek released in may of 2001.
with myers voicing the titura character
and fellow saturday night live alum and
multiplex hit machine eddie murphy the
four theatrically released films in the
series have combined to haul in an
astonishing 3 billion plus across the
globe that is living happily ever after
all right let's not overdo it so far the
connective tissue between myers and
kerry seems to be tons of blockbusters
and cameron diaz she plays stanley ipkis
love interest in the mask and provides
the voice of princess fiona in the shrek
films but no one can keep churning out
hits without a few duds not even will
smith and as carrie and myers continue
their careers their respective hit
making cooled off for different reasons
for mike myers he stopped starring in
movies i like my privacy which is a
guaranteed way to not make money on the
big screen after shrek iii he starred in
his most recent live action movie in
2008 that was the love guru and it only
took in 40 million dollars why do you
hurt me sent shrek forever after in 2010
myers has only been seen at small cameos
at movie theaters such as his portrayal
of ray foster in the hit queen biopic
bohemian rhapsody named for the song
that wayne and garth had rocked out to a
generation earlier but jim carrey's
remained a big screen stalwart right
through his current resurgence as dr
robotnik the thorn in sonic the
hedgehog's side a sequel is on its way
to theaters as we speak hot off the 300
million dollar grossing 2020 original
sonic live action movie carrie's also
dabbled in that lucrative animation
sandbox starring in hits like horton
hears a who and a christmas carol even
as those flicks team up to claim over
600 million dollars in box office
bullion most folks know jim carrey for a
different holiday tune 2000's how the
grinch stole christmas the subject of a
very lively episode of rotten tomatoes
is wrong took in 345 million dollars
recouping most of the extravagant makeup
costs required to turn ace into the
grinch so when we look at these two
careers head-to-head kerry has the edge
over myers in terms of total box office
bucks
5.32 billion dollars for the unliving
color fella to 4.44 billion for the snl
dude however myers's per film average
has a remarkable
278 million dollars carries is 166
million which would sound unreal if it
wasn't paired against shrek mike myers
is like that surfer that patiently waits
for the perfect wave before paddling out
carrie just stays in the water all the
live long day which means you're going
to fall off your board a few times like
with the incredible bert wonderstone or
i love you phillip morris or even man on
the moon none of those movies could even
amass 50 million dollars on their own
but for every misfire there's also a hit
like mr popper's penguins fun with dick
and jane or his all-time highest earning
movie bruce almighty which totaled 484
million dollars b e a beautiful so it's
average against career earnings myers
and kerry each have a solid claim in
this round but for me i tend to lean
more towards what you did on the
live-action side of the aisle animated
fair is for kids of all ages and the
shrek movies may be the best example of
that but most of the dollars spent are
because those little kids want to see a
jovial ogre and a kinetic donkey
regardless of what superstar is
providing the voice and if wayne's world
opened the door for a new wave of
comedic hit makers in the 1990s ace
ventura dumb and dumber and liar wire
kicked it down with the same veracity
employed by lawyer fletcher reed when he
beats the crap out of himself in a
bathroom i'm kicking my
mind
plate appearances matter in baseball and
in this round consider this nugget while
mike myers has made seven movies that
have crossed the 200 million dollar box
office mendoza line jim carrey has 14
such films to his credit and either guy
needed steroids to do it just a little
help from the dr seuss makeup department
i will award a hard-fought round one to
jim carrey and he goes up on his fellow
countrymen one to nothing yes
yes oh yeah can you feel that buddy
round two tomato meter slash audience
score and now the round that makes every
comedic personality shiver with fear
because we ask the question how'd them
critics like your movie game over i
don't sweat it too much i'm also going
to factor in the audience score here as
a matter of fact let's start with that
high note comedy is a fickle trade and
what one person finds funny the next
human may hate so what's the case with
wayne and ace they're both fresh
kinda the audience score has wayne's
world one at a solid b average which has
got to be the best grade wayne campbell
ever earned ah bite me at 84 percent
wayne's world 2 was also rosy at 63
percent and ace ventura has at least a
fresh audience score average with a
rotten 57 percent for part one being
helped out by a fresh 72 percent for
when nature calls carrie's audience
score per film average is 57 percent
aided by eternal sunshine with the
spotless minds 94 and 93 for sonic the
hedgehog and 89 for the truman show wow
that's amazing mike myers best carries
per movie average by a single point at
58
buoyed by shrek at 90 percent and
appearance in inglorious bastards at 88
percent and the og austin powers at 77
the mike directed super match about
legendary music producer shep gordon is
also resting comfortably at 84 percent
right next to wayne's world hey both of
those talkies prominently feature alice
cooper we're not worthy we're not worthy
we're not worthy school's out on the
audience score now it's time to feed the
frankenstein known as the tomato meter
how'd our beloved yuck yuck lads do with
the critics very well and also quite
horribly you see the love guru felt um
dated is a nice way to say it even upon
its release in 2008 and as a result it's
at 14
rotten on the tomato meter oh
what's even stinkier is meyers's
all-time lowest flick on that vine the
cat in the hat at nine percent oh boy
maybe the kid should not have answered
the door i'm a cat that can talk that
should be enough for you people but if
you think nine percent is low then
you're just now getting into numerology
jim carrey's throw with the number 23
which is sadly not about michael jordan
checks into the game at 8 percent rotten
i didn't really have
a lot to do but it's not even his
basement yep jim carrey is a member of
the zero percent club thanks to dark
crimes from 2016. look i told you what
happened okay so just drop it and now
the good tomato meter news the truman
show certified fresh at 95 percent and
the hit comedy liar wire blue pens its
way to a sterling 83 percent
[Music]
however both ace ventura movies are
rotten with when nature calls landing at
just 25
the great news is that dumb and dumber
is fresh at 68
yes the sequel is 30 which is why it
lives in the basement wearing an iron
mask
that is a good one
mike myers has trademarked characters
fair better than jim's on the tomato
meter as shrek 2s at 89 percent shrek 1
is it 88 and the first outing for
wayne's world and austin powers are also
fresh at 79 and 73 respectively like the
audience score metric mike myers bests
his competitor jim carrey by a single
point on the tomato meter when it comes
to per movie average 53 for mike 52 for
jim carrey's output helped him gut out a
win in the box office round but it might
have clipped his wings here no
well for now wayne and garth have earned
those aerosmith backstage passes because
mike myers gets his first win of the day
and we got us a tied ball game or hockey
match it's one to one i promised myself
i wouldn't cry
round three best characters
both jim and mike and i feel like i can
refer to them by their first name we all
know each other right
they were babysitting me as a kid
man
you are one pathetic loser
okay look i'm gonna keep a professional
both dr robotnik and dr evil i didn't
spend six years in evil medical school
to be called mister thank you very much
grew up in working-class families in
canada and long before carrie and myers
earned their big screen medical degrees
they had to develop a sense of humor and
for both their comedy chops were born
out of a sense of desperation the
details of my life are quite
inconsequential
mike myers was always told growing up
that he wasn't the funniest one in the
family as a matter of fact his own
household considered him the least funny
person at the dinner table which i admit
is both bogus and sad but once he
started training with the famed second
city comedy troupe and landed a spot in
1989 on snl he made use of his family's
frequent guffaws for the benefit of an
international audience many of his
quirky characters to be were reminiscent
of his father including the dad of myers
lead role and so i married an axe
murderer and when you hear that old guy
talk it might remind you of another mike
myers creation that would be unleashed
upon the world and buffets everywhere a
few years later but before we get to
that belly let's take a closer look at
jim carrey's upbringing i surpassed
everything you're ever going to do
[Music]
before i was a toddler doing his best to
entertain his sick mother while
attempting to escape the end-meeting
jobs he had to take on as a mere
teenager so he got fired again huh oh
yeah
they always freak out when you leave the
scene of an accident you know
kerry became proficient at imitating not
only his own family but famous
celebrities like james dean clint
eastwood and jack nicholson
the most powerful handgun
that unique talent was further honed on
stand-up stages like yuck yucks in
toronto and later at the world famous
comedy store where he got a job
answering phones just like the host of
this show versus nothing i'd call a
career jim's knack for spot-on
impressions would serve him well in
roles like man on the moon where he took
on the very spirit of andy kaufman watch
the netflix doc and later in the based
on a true story dramedy i love you
phillip morris but when it comes to the
most iconic characters ever played by
myers and carrie we usually think of the
ones that they dreamed up seemingly out
of thin air wayne campbell was loosely
based on mike myers friends growing up
while jim carrey played ace ventura like
the double 07 of the pet detective
circuit hot on the heels of ace other
carry classic roles like stanley ipkis
the mask and lloyd christmas and dumb
and dumber quickly became all-time
greats and i would also toss the cable
guy into that mix chip douglas or
whatever name he's going by now has
become a cult hero to anyone who ever
tried to slip the cable guy a 50 bill
for all those premium channels
you mean illegal cable as carrie's
career continued to soar he showed his
versatility in nailing more grounded
folks ranging from truman blissfully
unaware of the world he's in
who you talking to to his role in
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
just simply a guy who wants to be
blissfully unaware of the heartbreak
he's currently feeling but comedy lovers
needn't worry he was still making hits
as lawyer fletcher reed and liar liar
and as a menace to himself and society
in me myself and irene even fictional
folks born long before carrie ever did
an open mic were given a fresh spin like
batman forevers the riddler and dr
seuss's the grinch some kids grow up on
carrie's grinch but you won't find as
many kiddos who swear by mike myers cat
in the hat rendition well what are you
gonna do but that's not to say mike
petered out after wayne's world he was
just getting warmed up remember how
carrie made double 07 into a dolphin
locator mike myers took the more direct
spoof approach with his james bond and
the result was an international man of
mystery named austin powers those films
alone show the range that mike myers has
austin has catchphrases and mojo to burn
at the same time he's playing dr evil
powers nemesis and polar opposite in
terms of looks and attitude the sequels
heightened the multi-character showcase
as fat bastard capitalized on the
comedic promise showed by the axe
murderer movie so if you've made it this
far i'm assuming you enjoy a scottish
accent well you're in luck myers would
go on to voice shrek an ogre who
originally had none other than chris
farley as his voice after farwey's
tragic passing myers stepped in with his
normal vocal range but upon further
review mike asked to re-record shrek as
scottish the move cost dreamworks a
reported 5 million dollars but y'all
remember the box office round i'd say it
was a worthwhile investment aren't we
lucky we were there to get all that
information
it seemed extraneous at the time it
shouldn't be forgotten that mike myers
can also do drama proven by small roles
like steve rubell in 54 but his output
simply can't match what carrie has done
especially post-millennium mike myers
has no doubt left his mark in terms of
genius character creations that we'll
celebrate for generations to come but
carrie's prolific penchant for constant
reinvention gets him the nod in round
three and he takes the win it's two to
one with jim on top are you mental round
four cultural legacy
it's an enormous feat just getting by in
hollywood whether it's in the movies at
a recording studio or on the lighted
stage but much higher than even those
dizzying heights is where the legends
that are mike myers and jim carrey
reside they did far more than just eek
out a living or have a successful run
for a few years they've cultivated a
resume that features hit movies so
ingrained in the cultural zeitgeist that
we walk talk and act like they're
characters sometimes without even
knowing that it's them we're imitating
who amongst us hasn't uttered a yeah
baby and alrighty then or proclaimed
excellent we'll put our pinky up to our
mouth to look devious and anytime a
sports announcer gets an opportunity to
reference an underdog team looking for
an upset you will inevitably hear so
you're telling me there's a chance well
both myers and carrie have a good chance
to pull out a win in this round because
we'll look at the lasting impact that
their lines delivery and infectious
personalities have had on our lives to
look at wayne's world as just a lucky
break that inspired many other less
lucky sketch-based movies is entirely
too simplistic when wayne and garth hit
theaters audiences were looking for
something fresh and new and the advent
of the 1990s and the ascent of gen x
provided the perfect opportunity for a
revolution led by two simpletons imagine
being able to be magically whisked away
to
delaware
hi
i'm in delaware except myers and dana
carvey were anything but simplistic
themselves wayne's world could appear to
be dumb comedy but it was made by very
smart people but one could argue that
the small aurora-based cable access show
was just the opening act for a headliner
like no other 1994 ushered in a comet
named jim that became the next big thing
in comedy you can count on one hand the
amount of superstars who had a comedic
run anywhere close to carrie and by the
time his 1994 season was done and we saw
lloyd christmas desperately sprinting
towards the hawaiian tropic bus to alert
them of a nearby town's whereabouts
hollywood had been forever changed but
whereas jim carrey's career continued to
soar and saw him earn a number of golden
globe nominations wins and oscar buzz
since 2000 carrie has never quite found
the same magic as that initial surge
which is understandable because
replicating that run would be impossible
mike myers can't compete with a steady
stream of success in a variety of roles
like carrie he also won't ever match the
award nominations of his competitor
today but that's not necessarily needed
for this round because he had two other
grand slams that could seal the deal
austin powers in the love goo who wrote
that shrek austin and shrek take it easy
throwdoe and one shrek came along it was
definitive proof that pixar did not have
a stranglehold on animation going
forward the big green guy his princess
and donkey counterpart are all still
staples of any family movie night thank
you very much i'm here till thursday
sometimes we reference mike myers
without ever knowing it or even
confusing it for another myers named
mike
this is his mess
awesome powers
said michael myers this is mike myers it
should be the halloween man this is a
halloween mess no the killer dude from
halloween oh you need jason no it's just
one of the thousands of examples proving
how influential mike myers and jim
carrey have been and it's something of a
mild upset i'm gonna give the win in
this round to myers despite my personal
history being a little more smitten with
carrie than mike he did land first and
he kept throwing haymakers so we're tied
at two to two heading into the final
fight daddy's back and now it's time for
the wild card round memorable moments a
legacy is firm as mike myers or jim
carrey could only be cemented by a
career chock full of legendary moments
and while myers pulled out the win as
more culturally influential the moments
that made these fellows might lean
towards carrie as he has a much deeper
and broader body of work than his
counterpart but when myras has a shot on
goal he usually sticks it including his
very first role as wayne campbell the
head banging to bohemian rhapsody scene
early in the first waynesworld flick
perfectly set the tone for the film that
followed it was as funny as it was a
gateway into wayne and garth's very soul
their run-ins with alice cooper
aerosmith and jim morrison were also
highlights and as i'm fond of reminding
you all this is one of the few times in
history that the sequel has been better
than the original
at least for me anyway
more chris farley chris walken and a
scene stealing story weaving roadie by
the name of del preston all add up to a
great time in wayne's world too capped
off by an endlessly rewatchable radio
station scene where the boys are guests
on handsome dan's show
remember kids you never want to meet
your dj heroes and that's how you like
to live your life is it just enjoy the
sound of their voice good stuff i think
people are getting really cranked ace
ventura when nature calls is a film that
like most other comedies couldn't match
the greatness of its predecessor
although there's many fans who would
argue its superiority being in the
theater opening weekend for the og ace
as an almost high schooler marked one of
the hardest laughing sessions i've ever
experienced from the opening hds package
delivery to his walk in and out of every
scene i simply could not believe one
person could be that funny the chuckles
continued with the effervescent buoyancy
of the mask and the laugh until it hurts
gut busters found in dumb and dumber
from limo driving to samsonite i was way
off jim carrey was a riot but i'm also
going to credit jeff daniels from mutt
cuts to an unfortunate bathroom mishap
at mary's house he had an astounding
performance that saw daniels hang with
one of the best to ever do it at their
apex
carrie's bathroom scene in liar wire
pairs nicely as does his entire
transformation for man on the moon and
how the grinch stole christmas austin
powers and its sequels rarely leave a
comedic stone unturned but for me
nothing beats dr evil and his
misunderstandings of modern culture
which we shall call
preparation h
or is over the top villainous laugh that
slowly dies out over what seems like
hours and even with shrek acting as more
of the straight player to donkey's
sideshow shenanigans let's also credit
myers with helping a franchise stick
around until we got the ultimate
memorable moment maker puss in boots
pray for mercy from
puss
but only one comedy legend can take home
a win today and for that consistently
funny energy from a line delivery and
physicality standpoint i got a role with
cable guy jim carrey stealing his
victory though were also those more
dramatic turns in eternal sunshine and
the truman show when we realized the
gravity of what our character is dealing
with in sunshine and what they will have
to reckon with in truman's collapsed
world it's been a hard-fought battle
between two of the greatest canadian
exports since maple syrup and poutine
but jim carrey and his cavalcade of
comedic carnage gets the win in this
round and thus he takes the match jordan
fades back swoosh and that's the game
carrie wins it for me but now it's your
turn dear viewer hit me up on social
media at mark ellis live with your tick
and if you ever make it to los angeles
chances are you'll find me telling jokes
at the world famous comedy store where
jim carrey found a home and employment
some 40 years ago that's all for me as
dr evil would say i bid you would do and
in the immortal words of stanley f
kisses alter ego this episode of verses
has been smoking
you